but in this universe
janet van dyne contracted a quantum
virus that correct
with her husband a quantum environment
you're just putting the word quantum in
front of everything a quantum zone oh my
god
that's
that's worst case scenario that's where
oh no it's not good
welcome back to new rock stars marvel
studios what if episode 5 asks what if
zombies
with spider-man wasp and bruce banner
leading an all-star team of sidekicks
leaving us wondering where this quantum
virus came from and if it could have
been engineered for thanos to inevitably
get infected with it
what the is
this is inside marvel it's our after
show for marvel's what if on disney plus
i'm eric voss my easter egg breakdown is
coming to the channel tomorrow but right
now i'm reacting to this uh the whole
ifed up episode with mt
dude what is going on dude this episode
was kind of crazy like it was so cool
seeing marvel zombies done in the mcu i
never thought that would ever happen and
this uh lineup of specific characters
like i love seeing a conversation
between wasp and peter parker and uh and
happy hogan and sharon carter it's just
like an interesting alignment that i
didn't know that i needed but right such
a fun chemistry between these characters
right oh my god that's what's great
about the animated medium is because you
could have all these weird scenarios
like this so based on a walking dead
creator robert kirkman's 2005 marvel
zombies comics but really only loosely
despite producers of the show saying
this episode would stick closest to its
comic inspiration i don't know about
that
but this episode goes down during the
infinity war events when bruce banner
returns to earth to learn a virus
carried by janet van dyne from the
quantum realm wipes out the population
including most of the avengers but bruce
joins peter parker and hope van dyne
happy hogan bucky barnes okoye sharon
carter and kurt from uh the x-con
organization of scotland
uh david dostmouche character as a
polka-dot man as he's known in dc world
as this group hops a train to jersey to
a signal that they think is coming from
t'challa at camp lehigh uh and along the
way a bunch of them die but at this
space they find vision and futurama head
scott lang and vision has lured them
there we learned to feed his love zombie
wanda um but vision has found a way to
stave off these zombies to kind of keep
them at a distance by using a reverse
frequency from the mind stone because
this is a virus that affects brain
chemistry uh and vision gives them his
mind stone out of remorse so that they
can use it as a cure they hope to
reverse the brain signal causing the
virus uh and banner ends up staying
behind hulking out to fight wanda uh and
you know but this episode cuts away from
what should have been an amazing fight
to show a conversation in the jet sure
cool whatever uh and then uh peter and
scott and t'challa fly to wakanda but
like many great zombie stories it's not
a happy ending it's zombie thanos
waiting for him with all the stones in
his gauntlet except the mind stone oh
gosh ah
night night
[Laughter]
oh my god i really want this follow-up
episode so badly like so badly yeah
there's so much more story to tell here
and we got to talk more about this
quantum virus how it's different from
the marvel zombies comics and how it's
really really important that thanos now
has it um but before we get to that our
merch partners at epic hero shop have a
brand new latest obsession design
inspired by xiongchi we call it great
protector along with this what if design
both of these are limited edition
they're not gonna last forever so you
gotta head over to newrockstarsmerch.com
to grab both now especially that shang
cheese shirt uh i i can't wait to get
mine in the mail it's a great way to
celebrate this amazing movie
so jump on that and the nice thing about
is when you buy one of our latest
obsession shirts you get the chance to
leave a custom shout out that will run
on along the bottom of the screen during
our inside marvel episode some of this
week's shout outs include michael saying
hey boss do you think nightmare could be
involved with the events in spider-man
no way home
uh like mevisto nightmare could be and
might be and is involved in everything
bad in your life so
yes
i think characters will say the word
nightmare in the movie yeah will it be
capitalized in
we'll pretend it is until a version of
this comes out with closed captioning uh
but uh short answer i think this movie
is pretty stuffed i think if there is
some kind of cosmic entity i think it'll
be uh maybe one that shows up in the
post-credits scene uh dean asks what if
bruce banner turned back into human
after the blood transfusion for she-hulk
oh referencing uh some events spoiler
warning for shung chi
in the shang chi post criticism but
uh but that's an interesting take i feel
like we will get that answer of why he's
no longer in hulk form in she-hulk so
the blood transfusion is an interesting
way to go i don't know if that would be
enough like a needle wouldn't be able to
puncture banner's skin uh as these hulk
so i don't know how they'd get that
transfusion from him
uh when he's in hulk form yeah that'd be
really interesting to see if they were
to do that while he was in hulk form but
yeah it would probably be in a bruce
form after you know whatever i'm
assuming that whatever happened like the
the events of infinity war when he
snapped after that like him and hulk
could not be together like in the
professor hulk films form so uh yeah
yeah
and then corey asks kayleigh will you go
see shang chi with me
from corey
yeah kaylee go see
with corey it's a good movie corey
yeah uh or whatever
go watch this movie together it's
fantastic uh and if you haven't seen it
yet ignore what i said in the last
question
maybe i could have reordered these
anyway
uh empty what's our first question well
our first question of the day is what if
the quantum virus was engineered for a
reason ah yes empty with the true
question this episode of what if never
really got around to asking where did
this virus come from and uh as is the
case of many zombie apocalypse stories
was the virus engineered was there a
purpose was it weaponized for some
reason it's a government military lab or
testing on chimps like in 28 days later
where did it come from what was a
quantum real monkey they're making
militarized zombies that's what they're
doing the army
well this episode confirms no exact
origin of the zombie virus it says only
janet van dyne contracted a quantum
virus that corrupted her brain and then
later vision says mind stone emits a
frequency that repels the zombies and
banner asks
could that mean the infection is some
kind of encephalopathy
and that word just means any damage or
disease that affects the brain clearly
someone on the writing staff just looked
up what that word is and didn't want to
get too specific about it uh but that
just
for banner in terms of characterization
maybe a bit of a redundant question for
a scientist like him to ask me is even
in a world where he might not know what
zombies are he could clearly deduce that
this infection affects the central
nervous system in the brain it's kind of
like you wanted to sound smart is this
some type of
encephalopathy the word i learned on my
word of the day from miriam webster
today i like you and i are ragging on it
but we are struggling to get i can't
even say it
encephalophelophagus it's my favorite
exactly edible
but what i liked about this empty is it
does bring up an important point in
zombie fiction that i think not enough
people talk about uh characters that
seem dumb or kind of uninformed or naive
in zombie stories really need to be
forgiven because they live in a
fictional world often with no zombie
fiction to learn from you and i my
friend grew up watching you know 28 days
later and the walking dead and the
georgie romero movies not me my heart is
soft and i'm weak
well you don't have an excuse you've had
all this research
you can read world war z don't watch it
read it and uh you could learn
everything you need to know but that
would explain why characters are are
slow on the uptick like on the walking
dead when you see like rick in the
hospital like what's going on he didn't
have his own walking dead to watch or
read to learn that this is something
that could happen but i will say i wish
that could be said for the mcu but uh in
wanda vision um they are totally
screening george romero's night of the
living dead in the town square on the
halloween episode they do reference
plenty of other pop culture that you
could connect to zombie folklore peter
even asks does anyone here watch horror
movies uh scott lang references when
guardian leviosa and the harry potter
books the movies they're the uh the
corpses the inferioi whatever from the
cave in uh half blood prince so
they should know what zombies are in
this world
fine anyway visions revealed that the
mind stone frequency repels the virus
might tell us that part of the mind
stone's cosmic wisdom because remember
this stone in particular can kind of
talk to people like it's spoke to vision
and infinity war it has a divine
intelligence to it and i believe that it
wanted these surviving avengers to
transport it like mules to the desired
destination that it wanted in thanos
gauntlet i think the goal was for it to
get to thanos so just to catch you up on
what happens in the comics in kirkman's
marvel zombies the virus is called the
hunger and it leaves the infected with
their mental capacity still intact like
they can still talk to people they they
like trick people they're almost like
vampires uh you know in that sense but
they just are cannibalistic they they
need to eat and consume each other um
but the virus in the comics
one the coolest thing about the comics
is that it like crosses realities we
actually start like in the ultimates
comics and then we meet reid richards
from another dimension and then he is
actually secretly infected with it and
then we later zoom out to realize that
you know uh all these different
realities are being infected and it was
actually from originally the uh the
watcher of a specific other universe
called earth z who sent a zombified
century from his reality to earth 2149
and then the plague spread from there
what a jerk yeah
uh we're lucky to have the watcher we
have let's just say that yeah we're
lucky we have one who just doesn't
intervene
but it's not stated in the episode but
the fact that janet got the virus
mysteriously from the quantum realm
suggests that this version of the zombie
virus also could have come from
multiversal origins and i think it was
given to janet specifically so that it
would end up affecting thanos and
preventing him from snapping half of all
life let me try to explain this theory
um so what would a zombie thanos do when
he has all six stones would he snap away
half of all life well the quantum virus
leaves one with the physical capacity to
use their tech like iron man tech pym
tech falcon attack uh we see those
characters using those versions of their
attack so he could use the infinity
gauntlet however he wanted we also know
that characters still have their magic
so like the sorcerer is long and strange
wanda maximoff still has their magic
ebony maw can still use magic even after
he's zombified but it erodes their core
character identity they no longer have
their wants their needs their goals
their ambitions so zombie thanos
theoretically probably wouldn't snap
away half of all life with a complete
gauntlet he would probably use it to be
like a zombie god or potentially turn
all life into zombies but realistically
if you are a zombie what do you need
more than anything else non-infected
flesh to feast on
so you could argue that thanos would
spawn
a consistent flow of just normal life
the opposite of what he was trying to do
in infinity war is he just spawning
babies like it's just like hey well baby
or something i would say adults there's
more there's more meat on that bone uh
but i just think that it's interesting
that as of infinity war the quantum
realm was really the non-magical marvel
heroes one physical gateway to alternate
dimensions in the sacred timeline like
you could access the multiverse from
there just by shrinking subatomically
you don't really need magic to get into
it so anyone from outside the sacred
timeline or from another dimension would
view the quantum realm as kind of this
like
this buffer uh transfer way station
right and or they could see it as kind
of like the source of the spring water
the aquifer that if you uh poison that
water uh the stream will flow into our
sacred timeline anything you put in
there seeps up to the surface so i
believe that the quantum virus was
engineered as an experiment in order to
find its way to thanos right before his
stone quest in order to stop him from
killing half of all life and instead use
his divinity to create more life
it's just in a weird roundabout way of
being a zombie you're gonna want more
food in his makes a lot of sense life
forms and i think that the creator of
that virus could have been i'm looking
at two culprits here my first thought
went to kang right as someone who has uh
chronopolis is right there we think in
the quantum realm uh at like these next
points of these different time vortexes
that could lead to different branch
timelines uh it seems like a place where
kang might tuck his kingdom and conduct
various experiments maybe to see if he
could biologically bypass an absolute
point of thanos snapping the six stones
um but i also feel like it could be the
ultimate biological engineers of the
universe the celestials they're the ones
who create life they're the ones who
want to see how things play out and
conduct these experiments so maybe they
try to create a life influx-induced
energy surge to trigger a premature
emergence because we know after the snap
or after the blip when life returned to
earth according to the eternals trailer
that is what is triggering the emergence
for them so maybe in this reality
they're trying to do that earlier so if
the mind stone played any cosmically
active role in making sure that the
avengers got it to where it needed to go
i think these these infinity stones
originally were held by different
celestials the way east on the searcher
had the power stone right so i'm
wondering if the celestials who i've
theorized before might have given thanos
the mind stone to begin with back in the
early days before his invasion of earth
uh i think the celestials could have
really played a role in this virus what
do you think mt am i am i reaching too
much here i don't think you're reaching
at all with the celestials in because
like their whole deal was you know
working on things on a microscopic level
on a genetic level to you know alter
humanity so this could very well be a
the workings of the celestials or maybe
even you know the the aspirants like
that we have we haven't seen the
aspirins yet in the mcu but like they're
the the evil celestials so like maybe
the aspirants would want to infect the
reality or something and or you know
whatever but like yeah i think the idea
that the celestials you know uh
infecting janet on uh you know on a
subatomic level makes a lot of sense
because like they probably would want to
run like a zombie experiment on earth to
see what happens or like like you said
to push the mind stone more towards
thanos to fulfill this cosmic need but
like i like the idea um
like when you're talking about thanos i
was thinking what if
you know
the the life that you say that thanos
comes in and it feeds these zombies what
if they're like the people that were
snapped from other universes because
like they just like transferred over to
this universe like all right let's feed
the zombies now like everybody that got
snapped and like from a universe that
doesn't you know have a blip that
returns people back it's like yeah just
eat these people from the other universe
that thanos snapped and uh i don't know
i feel like this would be really fun
that's an interesting idea well i was
gonna ask uh the six infinity stones can
they affect uh things in another
universe first for whatever reason i
feel like they're limited to one's own
universe that that is surprisingly one
pretty big limit that was kind of the
implication of loki right by showing
them in the drawer that once you leave
your universe the infinity stones don't
have the effect the jurisdiction see
that that's actually kind of interesting
because like i don't know if because we
don't really know where the tva is so
like that could be outside of every and
all universes so like that's why the
stones don't work in the tva but i think
the infinity stones as long as you're in
a physical universe that isn't like you
know the dark dimension like as long as
you're in a universe with light in it
you could probably use the stones
interesting so any universe uh can have
yeah cause that was a question a lot of
people were asking about the void right
so like once b15 uh swiped that evidence
drawer then presumably that went to the
void giving anyone down there a drawer
full of infinity stones to use would
they be useful is the void connected to
the tva or the citadel is that
considered a place without light
i would say that the void
i i
correct me if i'm wrong but the void was
like at the very like end of like the
penultimate like thing at the end of
time right like the last thing correct
yeah it seemed like the it was right
adjacent to the citadel right if eliath
if like you pass through eliath
he that cloud is kind of what separates
you i'm i i've had a lot of different
models that i've sketched out to try to
show
where everything is spatially uh i'm
probably you i need a fourth dimension
of reality to be able to see it but
i at one point drew like the tva's a
giant ring
and then within that circle is the void
and within that circle the donut hole is
the citadel but then i realized it
should be the opposite right the tva is
the donut hole
outside the tva is another ring of the
the void and then outside of that ring
is like the citadel at the end of time
and in the middle of the ring is dante
from dante's inferno
yeah yeah yeah
no i think that that's
wrong but that's just how it works i
feel like that makes a lot of sense i
mean you feel like the whole concept of
the void and like how they explain it in
loki i like loki season 1 was great but
like i feel like they could have done a
better job at explaining because it's
just kind of confusing well they they
did uh they tried to keep it from a
narrow perspective but that uh episode
six opening intro as much as i loved it
like you're showing a god's eye view of
everything is we're pulling out from a
universe and then you just like you're
in the time stream the sacred timeline
ring and then you like you drop out of
it like marlin
in finding nemo out of the stream with
all the tortoises and then now we see
this floating rock and then we don't
know where we are still like we're in
space somewhere
and still young bro yeah
we're going through time dude
but here's your opportunity to just show
your map of middle earth like i want to
see where everything i love maps that's
what i loved about game of thrones
beginning of episode we started with a
big map just showing where everyone is
which pisses off in the later seasons
when characters are jumping across the
continent in a matter of hours
but it was cool for a while um anyway we
have gotten way off topic coming back to
this
idea i think my issue with um
with needing a reason why janet got the
virus you know this idea that it's
engineered is um while the show's
thematic uh take is that things can just
happen like accidents can happen and
that leads to all these consequences so
far every episode it seems like uh
there's been a very deliberate choice
that led to this alternate reality peggy
carter says no i think i'll stay
um
uh the
the what's it called the ravagers abduct
t'challa instead uh which was an
accident but we saw what led to it you
know right here it's just like
janet van dyne stepped on the wrong
cactus
and
now she has a virus we don't know what
happened we've seen characters walking
around the quantum realm with their
masks off and stuff and they seem to be
okay
like
where did she wander into
that this time like it's like they kind
of avoided it and i feel like we're back
talking about the falcon winter soldier
where the characters are talking about
as a virus outbreak and are afraid to
talk about the origins of it
no i think it'd be really fun
to see if like i think it's a really fun
implication though because like what if
there are creatures within the quantum
realm because we see an anime in the
wasp there are like you know creatures
flying around there and being kind of
weird um but if there were creatures in
the quantum realm that just had that
zombie virus in them and that like our
janet just dodged a bullet like just
didn't interact with them or or maybe
janet got remarried in the quantum realm
and her husband gave her an std that was
wasn't very good
unfaithful yes
it did look like some of the animation
design of the uh the quantum realm this
time it was like more it had some like
ashy looking elements to it or some uh
some sludge looking uh textures that was
not there in ant-man and the wasp so i
wonder if that was like deliberate to
show like ooh no no no this is a dirty
part
she was swimming in a florida retention
pond and then got sick for a week that's
lots of reality we were up doing this
every summer
uh it just happened but uh i guess my
question mt is when you're watching a
zombie story i guess you said you didn't
really grow up watching these zombies
well like you know as an adult
as an adult you have okay do you need
the answer of where the virus came from
i i don't need it but like just as like
i'm a curious person and a very like
science-y loving person i think it'd be
fun if you're just like oh it came from
like this little animal it's like
something small but like i don't need it
most of the time
you do get a sense of it just kind of a
vague implication of uh government
testing or military experiments or
something like that i believe for years
in the walking dead you know we don't
really know we don't really care but at
least walking dead the show has this
interesting twist where everyone in the
world is already infected with it it's
just however they die they don't need to
be bitten whenever they die if they just
like you know step in a bear trap and
bleed out they're gonna turn into a
walker which i like that twist like yeah
like you don't necessarily have to say
where it came from but you do need to
show how your world is unique and
different um and like and how the
mechanics of the zombie virus are
different and the site that was the
implication of the walking dead is like
oh maybe this wasn't government testing
this was at that moment when rick says
at the end of season two
like it almost feels like oh this was
like an apocalyptic like nature
basically said humanity's done yeah and
humanity just kind of evolved this weird
kind of genetic syndrome where we all
have it no matter what we're all
infected and i thought that was a really
cool
twist
what if that's what they're the seeds
that they're putting in in the mcu what
if everyone's secretly infected and like
janet just like i don't know just pushed
it further because like we do know that
the quantum realm is some link to
evolution like janet says in ant-man 2.
so what if what if there's just like
innate we have a zombie gene just like
we have a
x gene
well i'd want to see the implications of
that mutant gene before i see learn
anything else if we see
a genetic blueprint of any character in
the mcu and they don't start talking
about mutants i'm going to be pissed
like get to it it's muted
uh well i think uh we can agree on this
that this episode would really benefit
from a part two i think there's so much
more stories specifically with other
characters who might still be alive like
thor and the guardians of the galaxy
characters we will talk about after the
break but before we continue uh we want
to thank manscape for sponsoring this
episode autumn is in the air and
pumpkins are in the patch and our
friends at manscaped are here to make
sure you don't carve your pants pumpkins
when you're grooming
make sure you're keeping things fresh
this fall with the leaders in mail
grooming in their brand new 4th
generation performance package join the
2 million men worldwide using manscape
by going to manscape.com marvel for 20
off and free shipping inside the
performance package 4.0 you will find
their lawnmower 4.0 trimmer weed whacker
ear and nose hair trimmer crop preserver
ball deodorant crop reviver toner
performance boxer briefs and a travel
bag to hold your goodies the fourth
generation trimmer features a cutting
edge ceramic blade to reduce grooming
accidents thanks to their advanced skin
safe technology it also has a 4 000k led
spotlight and it is waterproof get 20
off plus free shipping by going to
manscape.com
marvel for 20 off and free shipping
that's 20 off and free shipping by going
to manscape.com marvel for 20 off and
free shipping make your balls a priority
this fall choose manscaped your balls
will thank you your pants pumpkins will
thank you too
we also want to thank helix sleep for
sponsoring this episode you don't want
to sleep on a mattress designed for
someone else it's like making
abomination wear shangchi's shoes
there's no way he's gonna get that arch
support that he needs helix sleep has a
quiz that matches your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you they have soft medium
and fur mattresses mattresses great for
cooling you down if you sleep hot even a
helix plus mattress for plus size
sleepers i took the quiz and got matched
with the dusk lux helix mattress because
i wanted a medium firm mattress with
lumbar support that sleeps cool i sleep
great on my helix mattress it's way
better than my evil variant twin or my
abomination variant does the mattress
ships right to your door for free you
never need to go to a mattress store
ever again they were awarded the number
one best overall mattress pick of 2020
by gq in wired magazine so just go to
helix sleep dot com slash inside marvel
in their two minute sleep quiz they will
match you to a customized mattress that
will give you the best sleep of your
life helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our audience at helix sleep.com inside
marvel that's healingsleep.com inside
marvel for up to 200 off into free
pillows we also want to thank bluetooth
for sponsoring this episode guys there
is nothing sexier than
confidence and blue chew can help give
you the confidence where it counts blue
chew is a unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis but in chewable
tablets and at a fraction of the cost
you can take them anytime day or night
in between so you can plan ahead or be
ready whenever an opportunity
arises
the process is simple you just sign by
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days but the best
part it's all done online so no visits
to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations no waiting in line at the
pharmacy
past the peeps you guys look at those
peeps while people are staring at you
looking at the peeps drooling
trying to steal them out of the package
so embarrassing bluetooth tablets are
made in the usa and prepared and shipped
direct to your door in a discrete
package so if you could benefit from
some extra confidence when it's time to
perform bluetooth can help and we've got
a special deal for our audience try
bluetooth free when you use our promo
code inside marvel at checkout just pay
the five dollars in shipping that's
bluetooth.com promo code inside marvel
to receive your first month for free
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank bluetooth for sponsoring this
episode all right mt we might have been
burying the lead here but this episode
acknowledge the existence of uncle ben
in the mcu so what if uncle ben existed
and i will remind people we did see the
bfp initials on uh peter parker's
briefcase or suitcase luggage in
spider-man far from home but now we know
for sure that did not stand for
big parker
and franklin parker
that's what all the girls call peter big
parker in the building
so empty
what do you what did you make of this
reference to uncle ben bro i was just so
happy to actually hear the words uncle
ben uttered by a peter parker within the
mcu i just think it's really
like obviously like uncle ben existed
you can't have a spider-man without
uncle ben it's it's core to his
character but like it's just to hear the
words uncle ben
like amongst other mcu characters makes
me feel like all right spider-man's
actually in the mcu now i don't know
obviously he was but like it's just cool
to see like the uncle ben influence and
that uncle and peter still thinks about
uncle ben um yes universe and like it
sort of indicates to me that we'll
probably get an uncle ben either seen or
or something more concrete in no way
home but like what do you what do you
think about this what was your reaction
oh i'd love to see some kind of
reference to uncle ben in no way home
that'd be great to finally i know uh
when they rebooted the character in the
mcu in spider-man homecoming right and i
guess in captain america civil war they
wanted to avoid some of the plot points
that we saw in the the mark webb films
and of course in the sam raimi films and
like we've already seen uncle ben died
twice we don't need to see it again and
i think they were better off for that
but i think now that we're used to the
character now that many people's eyes
this is spider-man it'd be great to get
some kind of reference to what happened
there uh and i think that was one of my
favorite moments of this episode is just
because i was like why is peter parker
able to keep such a happy attitude
throughout the zombie apocalypse like
the kid seems very sensitive in the
movies he is affected by all kinds of
things his empathy is one of the best
attributes of his character so the fact
that he can just kind of laugh it off
was it was funny to see his video for
sure it did kind of remind me of
zombieland you know the rules i know
such zombieland vibes yeah i i loved
that but then uh it did leave that
question of how is he like this but then
when they finally explain he's like well
this is just something i got from aunt
may like if you're smiling if you stop
smiling it's like you're gone as well so
i love that i like that a lot i did like
that too
i but i just like this acknowledgement
of uncle ben and i think they can kind
of get away with it without it being
like too huge a headline because some
people just say oh it's just this
animated series but i hope
i hope i hope i hope that in in no way
home we can get some acknowledgement
even if it's just from peter talking
with alternate peter parker's and
they're like well what happened to your
uncle ben and maybe peter doesn't want
to talk about it and they're like i'll
talk about it
we process grief differently
this is weird
right
i think
i think it'd be super dope to actually
have a scene or some type of flashback
with uncle ben in it but i don't know
okay let me know what you think about
this we cast steve carrell because i
don't know about you but i feel like
steve terrell would be a fantastic uncle
ben where where is that casting choice
coming from i love steve carrell by the
way i just what do you think i just feel
like him marissa tomei and tom holland
would be so well good together in a
flashback sequence like they have really
good chemistry and i would be broken to
watch steve carell die like i would be
so sad to see that happen because i
don't know that would hurt i mean steve
carrell can like if like gray haired
steve carell i could totally see that i
could see that totally gray steve he
does have that thing though where like
steve girl is a fantastic actor has
played a number of dramatic roles but i
think for some people they will always
see the eyes of michael scott in there
yeah so it might be
i'd be a worried sitting in the theater
and people are laughing when he sees
steve girl go
[Laughter]
if like he gets shot and like it's just
a funny like it's just completely funny
he's like oh oh geez you got me
i mean one of the theories was what tom
holland wanted was for toby mcguire to
play uncle ben in the mcu i think that'd
be a a nice way to get um uh toby
maguire in there i'd rather just see
toby play peter and ultimate peter
personally um
but yeah i don't
i hope that they don't do his death the
same way that we've seen before like a
gunshot wound bleeding out on a sidewalk
i i'd rather it be just something
slightly different you know uh or even
like it's if it is something off screen
i don't know if we need the actor for it
uh but it does seem to be something that
the sony marvel movies have kind of
waited to show
what if like
uncle ben dies during the chitauri
invasion that'd be kind of crazy
yeah that is interesting that uh would
make peter being an avenger mean that
much more to him you know right because
he is avenging something from another
world attacking his family but speaking
of like peter parker's future what if
peter parker is destined to become a
sorcerer because there was this little
moment where he was wearing the cloak of
levitation and he's just like ah it
doesn't really fit right and then hope
vandyn says says you're gonna grow into
it it's just like this interesting like
what does that mean he's gonna grow he
already is like an avenger he already
has super powers in a super suit so what
do you think that to me i'm my mind
started racing for spider-man no way
home
yeah
i think that it would be super
cool for peta and i feel like it would
make sense in the context of this
universe the zombie universe because
peter parker is a huge nerd and like if
he knows that you know some magic in the
marvel universe is essentially science
he would try to learn this magic to see
to try to you know fix the problem
because like he's one of the last heroes
left in the world probably yeah it
doesn't have a doctor strange anymore
because dr strange is a zombie so like
he's like hey it's my responsibility
because like i'm one of the few heroes
left to try to be a sorcerer supreme
because who else is going to be but yeah
i think it's it makes sense for this
universe what do you think yeah for
whatever reason it made me think of uh
peter's new suit that he's getting no
way home where it's got like sorcerer
powers embedded in it like i think it's
the idea that peter is going to be
mixing with magic in the next movie and
uh
it's it's an ill-fitting combination for
him but i think by the end of the movie
he's going to be a bit not necessarily a
master of mystic arts but he's gonna
show some skills with like magic
whipping that he doesn't have at the
beginning of the movie uh so that's my
thinking is that he's gonna teach dr
strange a thing or two about the nature
of magic that dr strange didn't fully
understand ooh i want to see some of my
peter original like whip spells like him
using the little like his little symbol
like his handsome yeah yeah yeah
um our last question is what if thor
could have survived these events because
if you're replaying infinity war right
like thanos did catch up with the
guardians of the galaxy on nowhere uh he
grabbed gamora gamora would still
probably be dead in this reality because
thanos has the soul stone and the
reality stone uh he would have faced
some of them on titan but i don't know
if they would have thought to meet on
titan because that's only when like dr
strange and peter parker and iron man
made it to titan right right so uh so
it's not it's not clear exactly how
things would have gone differently but
thor either way would have gotten a
native lear to get his battle axe right
right um
and i think thor rocket and groot might
have been able to stay immune
uh from this
and uh i mean maybe they would have
gotten to wakanda at some point and he's
like bring nathan no no no no no
i just bifrost away uh but i think thor
could have survived this
uh and thor might still be out there
what do you think mt oh yeah like i i
definitely feel like midgar is still in
play and like we still haven't seen
party thor because like party thor is
some is a character that is rumored for
you know the future episodes so like
party thor could be part of this
universe and like we just haven't seen
him yet and like we're gonna see him in
a later episode that's gonna be a
continuation of the zombies um
universe but um yeah i think thor is
definitely a factor because like you
know gods can't really get bitten by
humans that can't really get affected
and we see that with the hulk even
though the hulk's not a god but like
he's just super adorable so the fact
that the hulk can't get bitten i'm sure
thor and all the asgardians will be fine
and probably we'll have to deal with
whatever's going on on midgard because
that is within asgardian jurisdiction
because that's you know
sort of what odinn does cause like those
are all of like
the people of earth worship as guardians
and so like that's a huge part of like
you know
asgardian's existence and like they
appreciate the mid guards worship so
like they have to address this so i'm
just curious to see how they do that's
why i think there's absolutely an
opportunity for um what if zombies part
two and just show how thor tries to
avenge the people of earth and and
or does the zombie virus spread to other
planets you know i think that is one
thing that zombie thanos would do i
think he would go planet to planet uh in
feast you know but i think uh that's
what i want to see i want to see this
the front of this battle wage on
titan on holla
on the scroll home world
on xandar you know nowhere i think uh
contraxia all these places i want to see
the zombie virus spread to them and
thanos leave that charge wise thor tries
to repel it i think there's a
fascinating story there oh yeah i think
that like you know like you alluded to
earlier like you know with the with the
comic material being a multiversal story
i think we could see these zombies going
multiverse and like that too yeah huge
multiverse tva the tva gets overran with
oh my god that is a what if right there
i want to see zombie mobius so badly now
you can't introduce that to me and not
give it to me boss what the hell man
we gotta see it let's see it i want to
see a zombie dancing he remains just out
of desk
well we'll leave it there for this
episode of inside marvel mt and i are
going to be back next wednesday with our
what if episode 6 reaction don't forget
to check out all of our great merch
options at new york source merch.com
follow me at eavos follow mt
mastertainment follow new rockstars
subscribe to inside marvel wherever you
get your podcast thank you for watching
we'll close with our favorite moment of
the episode
[Music]
you